is a real life case in which someone
lost their life
and in the other country movies it was
possessions but no one actually
died
hey you okay there
jesus i think i hurt someone
the fact that it was based on a true
story immediately i was like in a
wikipedia wormhole right
after watching this movie being like oh
my god this really happened this is
insane
i couldn't really find anything on like
where arnie and debbie are now did you
guys like
they're still around like did you guys
like talk to them or anything were they
involved with this movie at all
you know they were on set i yeah i know
but i have nothing much to tell you
because i usually keep my distance and i
can't even give you a good reason why
i just do they were there for a day
and that's also been part of each each
film that we've done the family that
we're
we're doing the story about they they'll
they'll come for a day or two and
you know see the set and see what's
going on and see where their
life story ends and then becomes
dramatized
i believe rory probably talked to him i
know actually sadly we just lost
debbie debbie just passed away quite
recently like like
very recently the past few months that
was that was certainly very sad but uh i
believe that
they um the two people playing them were
able to
talk with them but yeah we did sort of
st stay
away no it's interesting because i i was
trying to find stuff and it was like
half the family is like really against
the demonic thing and then the other
half is like
very supportive of it so i was just very
fascinated about that whole thing
it's a witch's totem we think your
family was cursed yeah i
only said hello briefly to debbie and
arnie
um i think i was filming quite a bit
seeing that today and also
i i kind of felt a bit strange about it
because it is a real life case
in which someone lost their life and in
the other conjuring movies
it was possessions but no one actually
died
so my relationship with that is kind of
is a funny one
um also like i'm definitely playing a
fictional version of it and
i i don't know what happened i'd love to
know i'm so
obsessed with true crime i just watched
nightstalker on netflix that was amazing
yeah um we have such a fascination with
that kind of stuff
we want to know exactly what happened
but in this case no one really knows
what happened
um i'm sure arnie is even confused at
this stage and especially the arnie i
play in the film he doesn't know what's
happened and why he's there he doesn't
know if he did it or if the demon did it
so that state of confusion is what i
lent into but sarah catherine had
a very different relationship with
debbie especially yeah i um
i was connected with debbie pretty early
on
in the movie and spoke with both her and
arnie over the phone for like an hour
and a half within like the first like
two weeks or something
um and debbie did most the talking like
what i learned about debbie was she was
she was no nonsense like straight
shooter she kind of felt like that
really funny aunt
that like everyone loves i spoke quite
i spoke pretty frequently with her
throughout the movie and like even
post-production as well like we kept in
touch quite a bit
um so i was very excited for them to
come
and i kind of just hung out with debbie
all day i was like i'm not leaving your
side if you are here for one day like i
just need to soak you all in
you know we had uh we had a bunch of
interviews from them so you know they
were definitely their story was you know
definitely in their experiences
definitely reflected in the uh in the
movie
you know and it's one of these things
that you know especially because
there's a real murder here there's a
real victim
at the core of the story and it's one of
those things that you know coming at it
you know
usually with these haunted house true
life stories you can come at it with
this healthy degree of skepticism i grew
up catholic so i'm always prone to
believe these things
um but you know all of a sudden with
this you know that
that thought experiment of like do i
believe do i not it's like put
really on trial in a way no pun intended
but you're
you're really asked to to consider what
you're believing
to to say you believe in this it takes
on a whole different way
the court accepts the existence of god
every time a witness swears to tell the
truth
i think it's about time they accept the
existence of the devil
you